[Music]
to trabajo nominate a Yamaha Yamaha
Molly moon American male Claude passo
Femina kuiba mrs. Gracia Tolu and
animatic hey I'm about to eat or [ __ ]
up an ode to my mother on cocaine acaba
Hannah for Dylan Amana you know followed
me luck or no luck yet in our abandon
Zilla I will see young Haley Togo Harold
a unit of an 11 on a Hawaiian with
Heather
[Music]
long considered the caviar of the east
birds nests are more specifically the
dried saliva of swiftlet Birds is a rare
treat these birds prefer to build their
nests in dark caves and in the
Phillipines nests gatherers go to great
heights literally to collect them -
wanna come see no young talented or
grassy my Masuka way back in episode ma
la palma de la vie nasa open in Menasha
octopus Oh Mowgli nice dolly Munna don't
concern see no on concessionaire in
event innominate Oh Samana
concessionaire in the novice engineer
phenomenon even in the nominal are good
McGowen
so the work may be dangerous but these
nest gatherers are willing to risk their
lives because the payoff is worth it
amber nice mega Mahon talaga one kala
one is one other fifty thousand pesos -
nononono na mean et noggin paganella
non-arab no Helene Amira honey - no
sighs laughs yes I'm sorry store on Main
Avenue EMI receiver on onion
traditionally the role of an s caterer
is passed down from generation to
generation so while this may seem
frightening for angelito it's an honor
mama it don't make it about that I go
Lala Nagisa nangbou nahi tu trabajo de
la nina nina hagen over my shadow Colin
and I a non-market number talked
recently yeah nine to see my mama an
option in the app or reading p'malee to
Sakuraba Anya you know man I'm agin
Kazama nom nom in Yad Alabama a second
beta particle toga sale the window
villain de seguros Hammami la casa
[Music]
visit the budget I had a second Granger
[Music]
Milverton came at akashavani to Sonali
Gionta nahin Tilly got another nickel
okey binary Manticore sorta deep in the
Himalayan mountains about 80 miles
outside of Katmandu the Bujang village
takes part in a death-defying tradition
all in the name of honey
[Music]
yo-yo Polly but I'm a journey or not
strong your honey cough gemstone that it
but procuring this precious honey takes
more than just strength a team of honey
hunters assembles twice a year to
prepare and Madan
he leads the pack finally you just AM
radio gonti Jody here are your gum time
system oil here what are you gotta go
you're a monocot even a movie theater of
this deep passion and dine today ancient
customs are still closely followed
before each hunt Madan must visit the
village guru to receive His blessing
open air Oh Bravo
okay no no secobarbital et cetera I was
a lady and era tikka masala dhaba till
Arab armies become got a junta
[Music]
one day Madan will fill the girls shoes
in the meantime he leads his team of
honey hunters into the jungle the team
braids and Bree secures their handmade
rope ladders
then they ventured to the cliff side
where the beehives are hiding the team
creates smoke fires down below to
encourage the giant bees to scatter
Madan lowers himself onto the Rope
dangling hundreds of feet from the
ground
Oh Moira neonatal a league or very much
a mother Sita
Chima Megara my name while a ackerman
gratitude tellen amar install a thermal
a given air by or about a delicate
little a married mother pani poori
Millie
what is it amalgam I get my limo team
despite the incessant stinging on his
unprotected skin he calmly cuts away at
the hive fulfilling his duty and
securing his liquid gold forever daddy I
have a dingy dirty fancier but it's all
a bit around that little turd even a
beauty
the hives are collected by the hunters
and packed up to bring back to the
village where their safe return is
celebrated yo Ramiro Genma de cadena ma
mère ubu billion Leonid Ramallah he owns
actively I need a gurney porta you
Millie you you can wear a mullet a dummy
sandy to be put on Ronnie Kalen better
our poor Connie whatever you Maury can
challenge a vaca Raja
[Music]
when people say they summit for the view
I think they're missing a lot of the
equation of why we do the things we do
the summit honestly is pretty
anticlimactic the movement is for me the
most exciting part
my name is Erik Weihenmayer and I'm the
first blind person to have climbed the
tallest peak in every continent
[Music]
when I was four or five years old I was
diagnosed with this incredibly rare
disease called retinas Qisas it attacked
my retinas and essentially unravel them
when I finally went blind it was a weird
relief like the worst thing had happened
so there's nothing else to lose
there was a recreational group taking
blind kids rock climbing and that was it
for me it was sort of the full package
of adventure all the things I thought I
wouldn't have as a blind person they
need 14 for this pitch yeah I'm counting
them right now okay when I get onto a
rock face I actually feel like I'm in my
element the things that sighted people
learn to do with their eyes I've learned
to do with my hands
when I'm clipping a bolt through a
carabiner I'm feeling it I'm making sure
it's correctly clipped and if I fall
that that carabiner is gonna hold me
[Music]
I can't look up the rock and see the
holds and plan a big route I can only
see as far as my hands
it's breathtakingly exciting sometimes
you hear those cars way down below you
in the floor of the canyon
I love that sound of emptiness a lot of
external stuff sort of disappears and
you're thinking about nothing but that
next hold in front of you
so it's very very meditative very much
kind of like an inner mind sport I like
that I think that's the best pitch could
you feel that space like the exposure
down there yeah I mean especially with
these trucks flying by down they kind of
echoes through the whole canyon and you
can hear everything yeah what do you say
we top out yeah let's um it's right up
here right yeah okay
as a blind climber it's really hard and
you just sort of have to embrace that
suffering
blindness is just a thing that happened
to me I think like all adversities we
got him use them as a catalyst to push
you in new directions it's the idea of
turning bad things into good things and
it's something I think we all could use
[Music]
right after school I just like China
like once to the gym so I can climb it
it's a dangerous all right but I only
think that I'm afraid of is not being
able to get seven
[Music]
with climbing I don't think that it
really matters it's how big you are if
you're a smaller you can hold on longer
and your hands light be small ways so it
can fit my finger it's on hold I started
climbing in Central Park
when I was six years old now I don't
think I can like live without it
[Music]
when we're close to the top of the time
you're trying to do your funds usually
feel like they're gonna explode and
they're gonna like first open and you
feel like you have to let go but with
climbing you just can't let go I think
that climbing is it's obviously a sport
it's also like a dance you sort of have
to be able to like flow up the wall and
come up with your own techniques to get
to accomplish
I think people shocked if I do something
that they can't do something because I'm
still really young and I'm a girl so
like doing something that even if a guy
can't do is pretty special
[Music]